be conééééééééééééééééééééééééééééé!!!!
Die ganze Zeit ist es nicht mehr so.
Ich bin schon mal wieder in der Nähe.
Die ganze Zeit ist jetzt auch damit.
Aber das ist so ein Kandidat, der immer diskutiert. Immer. Wegen jedem Scheiß, ja.
Kennen ihr, kennen ihr so Leute, die wirklich von, aus, von bei allem irgendeine Diskussion vom Zaun brechen?
So nach dem Motto, ich hab ne Tasse, da ist der Henkel links und ich hab ne Tasse, da ist der Henkel rechts.
Ist der jetzt links oder rechts? Vielleicht ist der sogar in der Mitte? Die müssen wegen allem die Diskussion vom Zaun brechen, ja.
Ja, die labern, ja, das stimmt, das stimmt.
Gut, so, so, so Stonks BWL, so Stonks BWL Consultant-Typen haben wir auch.
Die kriegen ja eh Geld, wenigstens nur fürs Labern.
Aber wenn du Technik, IT, Experten, beziehungsweise Consultant-Leute holst.
Der Name Consultant suggeriert ja irgendwo, den fragt man zu Sachen, wo man selbst keine Ahnung hat.
Aber dass diese Sache nicht der Fall ist, war mir schon eigentlich von Anfang an klar.
Und das beste Beispiel für mich, warum das nicht der Fall ist, ist unser Spezialazubi, von dem ich euch schon öfters mal was erzählen hab.
Also der, der so gar keinen Plan hatte. Der, der einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch hatte, wo ich ihn nach Netzwerkgrundlagen gefragt hab.
Genau der. Der ist ja dann weg bei uns nach der Ausbildung, weil ihn keiner haben wollte.
Und was ist er geworden? Junior Consultant. Mir fällt wirklich kein einziges Thema ein, bei was ich den konsultieren würde.
Mir fällt wirklich nichts ein, bei was ich den fragen würde.
Das einzige Talent, was der hat ist, das ist der mit C-Lattenzaun. Genau.
Der, der statt C-Sharp gesagt hat, das würde C-Lattenzaun heißen. Genau der ist das.
C-Lattenzaun. Genau der ist das.
Und der schon nicht geschafft hat, einen Body-Mass-Index zu programmieren.
Das waren Übungsaufgaben und das hat man ja dann hingekriegt.
Und irgendwann hat er gesagt, Max, es funktioniert. Max, es funktioniert.
Und im Endeffekt meinte er halt, es kompiliert.
Naja.
Nix wissen, Kohle schäffeln. Ja, ist echt so.
Max, was hältst du davon, wenn Workstations alle Mitarbeiter durch VMs auf einem Server ersetzen?
Nix.
Der Mitarbeiter hat also nur eine ArtKVM-Box auf dem Tisch mit. Kann das flüssig funktionieren?
Also, theoretisch schon. Praktisch, nun ja.
Also, ich würde den Unterschied sofort merken.
Irgendwelche Noobs, die halt absolut nix checken, was Input-Lag und Responsiveness angeht,
die nicht, aber ja, man merkt das auf jeden Fall. Es gibt ja da verschiedene Varianten.
Es gibt einmal diese Zytrex-Geschichte, die auch Grafikkartenbeschleunigung kann.
Und es gibt diese von Microsoft, diese Hyper-V-Geschichte, die auf RDP basiert, wo auch Grafikartenbeschleunigung ist.
Also, das ist quasi ein RDP, der allerdings irgendwie auch für die VMs eine GPU durchreichen kann.
Das geht nur Hyper-V-mäßig. Und ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt.
Und dann kann man dort auch über RDP 3D-Anwendungen benutzen und sowas.
Also, die Chance, es geht, es geht. Man darf nicht vergessen, im Endeffekt, wenn sowas wie Game-Streaming geht, dann geht auch sowas.
Also, wenn du Game-Streaming kannst, dann geht auch ein lag-freier Desktop. Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar noch einfacher.
Allerdings, ich bezweifle, dass die das richtig machen und wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Ich bezweifle, dass die das richtig machen und wahrscheinlich eher sparen wollen, dadurch, dass sie die Workstations ersetzen.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es gut funktioniert.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das gut funktioniert. Also, bei uns, wir haben so eine ganz primitive Geschichte.
Also, quasi eine Windows-VM, wo man per RDP drauf geht. Und das ist halt laggy as fuck, ne?
Also, der Unterschied zwischen lokal installiertem Windows und, na, vor allem mit RDP ist halt riesig.
Wenn es dieses spezielle GPU-Pass-Through-Hyper-V-RDP-Extension-Ding ist, dann ist es okay. Dann ist es ein bisschen wie Game-Streaming, würde ich mal sagen.
Aber Game-Streaming funktioniert ja auch nur so flüssig, weil es halt eine GPU durchgereicht ist. Auf der anderen Seite.
Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es gut funktioniert.
So, Runde T einschenken. Excellent.
Und gerade wenn man Windows hat, dann machen die doch eh alle möglichen Sachen über Regel im AD. Dann kann man doch auch Workstations behalten.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es einfacher ist von der Verwaltung. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auch spart...
Zockst du Hyper? Was ist denn Hyper? Ach, das ist das Ubisoft Battle Royale. Hab ich noch nicht angeguckt.
Ich hab mir nur mal einen Stream heute angeguckt. Ich finde, das sah auf den ersten Blick gar nicht mal so doof aus. Aber kann ich noch null zu sagen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, das spart Kosten. Und es ist einfacher zu verwalten. Allerdings die Frage ist, wie weit das wirklich Kosten spart, wenn die Mitarbeiter den ganzen Tag lecken.
Weiß man nicht.
Oh, habe hier noch meinen. Moment, Moment. GIF.
Wie ging das mit dem GIF? Muss man GIF starten? GIF. GIF. Ach nee, das hatten wir auf dem anderen. Das Allerwichtigste. Also, ohne GIF im Terminal geht da nichts.
Hast du das mit Wreckful mitbekommen? Ja, hat mich mitbekommen. Da gibt es ja eigentlich keinen Weg dran vorbei, das nicht mitzubekommen, wenn man ein bisschen sich da umguckt online.
Heute irgendwas geplant? Nee, ich bin ja auch noch eineinhalb Stunden da. Ich komme mal on. Ich komme einfach mal on.
Ah, hier, hier. Perfekt. Wo ist das? Wo ist das Paper, please? So, jetzt haben wir das Wichtigste, Leute. Jetzt haben wir das Wichtigste da.
Jetzt ist das Wichtigste da. Exzellent. Wie im Titel steht.
Ja, genau das habe ich vermutet, dass es laggy ist. Wie gesagt, die meisten bauen dir da nicht die ordentliche Geschichte auf.
Also da, wo du halt auch GPU hast in der VM, wo du LDP Extensions für 3D Beschleunigung hast oder gar sowas in der Richtung, wie man eben beim Game Streaming macht, sondern die machen halt eine billige Geschichte VM und LDP.
Und das ist halt laggy wie Sau. Da kommst du dir vor wie 1990. Schlechter.
Ein Raspberry Pi ist heute ankommen. Was hast du denn vor? Begrünen wir es? Na ja, dann lockst du dich halt daheim remote ein und kopierst dir den Code, wenn du willst.
Also wenn einer was klauen will, klaut er auch was. Man sollte vielleicht eher gucken, dass man Leute hat, die nichts klauen. Das ist bei uns auch so.
Wir haben überall übertriebene Berechtigung. Wir verwenden ja auf der Arbeit als Ticketsystem das hier. Das ist also eines der bekannteren. Hier, die Dinger da.
Hira. Es heißt übrigens wirklich Hira. Aber die richtig coolen Leute sprechen natürlich Jaira aus. Was übrigens komplett falsch ist. Ja.
Jaira. Es heißt nicht Jaira. Es heißt Hira. Hira. Es heißt es. Was? Haira? Nein, Haira. Nein, es heißt Hira. Das ist Japanisch.
Es heißt wirklich Hira. Zumindest. Ja, heißt es. Das sagen die sogar.
Japanisch Namen für Godzilla. Zumindest. Bei uns ist es so. Die übertreiben es komplett mit Berechtigung.
Also es geht sogar so weit, wenn ich ein Ticket habe, wo ich Bearbeiter bin und stelle fest, das ist bei mir falsch und verschiebe das in einen anderen Bereich, wo es richtig ist, dann kann ich das Ticket nicht mehr abgeben.
Weil ich in dem anderen Bereich ja keine Berechtigung habe überhaupt Tickets zu bekommen. Allerdings habe ich das Ticket ja noch, weil ich es zuerst in meinem Bereich hatte und dort das Ticket bekommen habe.
Das ist wirklich Big Planet und bei uns sind die Berechtigungen so wir, dass solche Sachen laufend auftreten.
Wenn neue Mitarbeiter anfangen, dauert das erst mal drei Wochen bis sie Zugriff über Allhaut drauf haben. Das ist so lächerlich.
Normalerweise würde ich erwarten, gerade wo die sich immer überschlagen von wegen, wir haben so geile Prozesse umgesetzt und sich selbst voll abfeiern, frage ich mich, wie es sein kann.
Warum gibt es dann keinen Mitarbeiter-Check-In-Prozess, dass es nicht so drei Wochen dauert.
Das ist nicht sonderlich agil.
So ist man nicht agil.
Und da bringt Jyra auch nichts.
Wie gesagt, da ist Jyra.
Und die haben schon so eine ekelige Seite, wenn ich das sehe.
Also mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen so, wenn einer will, dass sein Zeug verschimmelt, dann muss er es in irgendwelchen Atlassientools ablegen, dann findet es keiner mehr bei uns.
Das geilste ist, wir haben Teamnamen.
Also keine Ahnung, ich denke mir jetzt mal einen Teamnamen aus.
Sagen wir mal, wir hätten ein Team Software-Bereitstellung.
Haben wir nicht? Ich mache das ja ein bisschen anonym.
Aber theoretisch angenommen, wir hätten ein Team, was sich Software-Bereitstellung nennt.
Und man möchte ein Ticket aufmachen, im Ticketsystem, weil man auf seine Windows-4M-Foreverplayer braucht.
Zum Beispiel.
Da würde man ja von ausgehen, du gehst ins Hierer rein, machst ein Ticket auf bei einem Bereich, der heißt wie das Team.
Bei uns sind es allerdings Massive Big Brain und das Jyra-Team oder Atlassient-Team benennt die Gruppen im Hierer anders, wie die Gruppen wirklich heißen.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Also dann heißt das Team eigentlich Software-Bereitstellung.
Auf dem Organigram heißt es dann ITSW-DEF oder so.
ITSW-DEP, das muss überall anders heißen.
Und im Hierer heißen sie dann nochmal ganz anders.
Da heißen sie dann SWITPLUB, keine Ahnung.
Man findet nichts bei uns, das ist so geil.
Du kannst dich auf nichts verlassen.
Wenn du den Team-Namen weißt, findest du ihn nicht im Organigram und nicht im Hierer.
Hast du den Hierer-Namen, findest du ihn nicht im Organigram und nicht...
Richtig gut.
Aber Leute, meine Frage wer bei euch arbeitet bei einem größeren Laden, das ist fast überall so, gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus.
Also bei dem Provider, wo ich vorher gearbeitet habe, da war es nicht ganz so wild, das war aber auch nicht so ein ganz großer Laden, aber es war auch furchtbar wirr.
Kennst du Redmine? Ja, kenne ich.
Redmine, Alter.
Da sind wir zum Glück, das haben wir überlebt, Redmine.
Die Musik ist extrem paper please.
Also Redmine habe ich noch nicht aufgesetzt oder so, aber ich kenne das, ich kenne das.
Lukku, das richtig gemacht ist, das ist nicht schlecht.
Also ich muss sagen, so von den ganzen Ticketsystemen, die es gibt, wo ich schon mal ein bisschen so reingeguckt habe, finde ich Hierer eigentlich am besten.
Wenn es ordentlich gemacht ist.
Wie viele Mitarbeiter hat ein Unternehmen eigentlich? Endorphine, also ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, das weiß wahrscheinlich keiner so genau.
Weil das zig, Tochter und über und sonst wie, ach das weiß keiner.
Also ja klar, wahrscheinlich weiß es irgendeiner, aber so wirklich wie man es hier sieht, ist es wahrscheinlich keiner.
Ja, wahrscheinlich weiß es irgendeiner, aber so wirklich wissen tut das, wenn du nicht gerade Buchhaltungsmann bist, wahrscheinlich keiner.
Dann machen sie ja so komische Dinge wie, ja ok, jetzt müssen neue Leute bei irgendwie einer Tochtergesellschaft anfangen, weil man sonst über eine gewisse Anzahl käme,
wo es dann noch einen neuen Betriebsrat, Sitz bräuchte und so Dinge, das weiß keiner genau.
Das, das, das weiß, das weiß keiner genau.
Das ist schrecklich mit Ruby und Rails, ach Ruby und Rails an sich ist gut, aber Redmine ist halt eklig.
Ja wie gesagt, das mit Ragfall habe ich mitgekriegt, ich kann dazu gar nichts sagen, ich habe seine Streams nicht geguckt.
Ich weiß nur, dass er sich umgebracht hat mit 31 und dass er wohl schon längere Zeit ein bisschen Dachschaden hatte.
Aber genaues keine Ahnung, hat wahrscheinlich schon jeder auf Twitch ausführlich behandelt, ich muss es ja nicht auch noch unbedingt machen.
So, ich mache mal die ganzen Crap hier zu, die wir noch von gestern auf hatten.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen, das dürfte jetzt ja nicht mehr da sein.
So wie ist diese komische Seite nochmal mit diesen Jobs, die ich bemerken wollte, Jobs vor Andy, sowas, das beknackt das echt.
Ich wollte mich eben ein bisschen kaputt lachen, ich habe nichts spezielles vor sage ich euch gleich.
Habt ihr Dings mitgekriegt? Habt ihr Twitch Drama mitbekommen?
XQZ vs Ninja vs Ninjas Frau vs Ninjas Bruder vs XQC's Frau vs frag mich nicht alles.
Wie sie sich geflamet haben, ich habe mich so kaputt gelacht.
Wie sie sich geflammt haben, ich hab mich so kaputt gelacht.
Also wer es sich mitgekriegt hat, so die, so die, so die, so die, in drei Sätzen war
die Erklärung.
XQC hat im Stream gesagt, ähm, die meisten Streamer, die Charity Event Stream bekommen
Geld dafür.
Und darauf, darauf war irgendwie Ninja angepisst.
Und dann war Ninjas Frau noch angepisst und er hat XQC ihr geantwortet, so nach dem Motto
ja was war sie schon mit ihren zwei Gucci Handtaschen, sie hatte da auch gar keine Ahnung
von.
Dann hat Ninjas Bruder darauf geantwortet und Ninjas Frau, dann hat irgendwann noch,
noch XQC´s Frau darauf geantwortet und haben sich alle geflammt.
Ich hab mich so kaputt gelacht, das hat mich so ein bisschen an YouTube Drama 2012 verinnert.
Genau er ist Ninjas Frau, dann Ninja, ich fand´s mega lustig, eigentlich total unsinnig
wie sie sich da drüber gestritten haben.
Ahja, kann mir jemand mit dem Raspberry Pi helfen, ähm, Noobs, Noobs ist für´n Arsch,
nehm´ ne SD-Karte, mach den Raspian drauf, vergiss Noobs.
Gibt es eigentlich schon was neues zu Prime, also diesen Streaming Service, ich bezweifle
auch das es den geben wird, erstens, erstens, also da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen, erstens
die zuverlässigste Quelle davon ist 4Chan und ich finde das sagt alles wenn die zuverlässigste
Quelle 4Chan ist, so, ähm, und das nächste ist, ähm, Prime, der Name ist viel zu, viel
zu, ähm, ähnlich zu Prime, würden die das wirklich rausbringen, da wäre Amazon sofort
am Starten, wird die verklagen, weil Prime und Prime zu ähnlich ist, ne, also wie gesagt
zuverlässigste Quelle 4Chan und Prime und Prime, das wird´s dem Leben nicht geben.
Ähm, was ist deine Theorie zu Dr.
Disrespect?
Gut, habe ich ja schon vor ein paar Tagen gesagt, als es aktuell war, meine Theorie
ist immer noch Plattformwechsel, weil für alles andere brauchst du zu viele unbekannte
Sachen, da halte ich Plattformwechsel tatsächlich für am wahrscheinlichsten, was es am Ende
ist, wir haben alle keine Ahnung.
Welches Einstiegsgehalt kann man als Informatikstudent, Moment, du bist Informatikstudent, also du
hast vorher eine Physi-Ausbildung gemacht und bist jetzt Informatikstudent.
Möchtest du quasi neben dem Studium noch was, noch was verdienen?
Oder bist du fertig mit dem Studium?
Ach du wirst fertig, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, aber ich habe gesehen, dass
die Bahais letztens wieder ihre Gehalts, äh, Gehaltsumfrage gemacht haben, das ist immer
ganz gut, weil es für Deutschland ist, genau, was ist mit euch los heise, come on bra, Paywall
wollen die mich veräppeln, ja aber nee Paywall dann halt nicht, ja, lull.
Also ich habe keine Schmerzen damit, dass die heise plus haben, die müssen ja auch irgendwie
Geld verdienen, aber vielleicht sollte man nicht auf der normalen Seite heise plus Artikel
dann irgendwie verlinken, weil ich fühle mich immer angepisst, wenn ich irgendwo drauf
gehe und fange an, vor allem das Bahais ist das nervige, das fängt hier unten immer
erst an, ja, du scrollst, du drüberlängst dir, aha, aha, aha, aha, ah, Paywall, also
irgendwie zwei Minuten verschenkt für da oben, weil Paywall voll von Arsch, also 40k
ist auf jeden Fall für, also es kommt immer ein bisschen aufs Gebiet ab, aber 40k erscheinen
mir auch wenig, ja, es kommt natürlich drauf, also es kommt extrem auf die Region an, aber
40k erscheinen mir, also mal, wenn es Frankfurt wäre oder so auch ziemlich wenig, es kommt
natürlich nicht nur darauf an, dass du, es ist halt auch die Frage Region und welche
Position das ist, ich meine, wenn du jetzt in Support gehst, wir haben bei uns im 24-7-Support
auch einige Bachelor-Studenten sitzen, die Informatik studiert haben, dann kriegst du
auch nicht viel, weil Support wird dann nicht bezahlt, also, na, es kommt drauf an, welche
Stelle und es kommt drauf an, welche Region, dann kann man was sagen, ehm, immer Proto,
also von netto Jahresgeld redet kaum einer, auch die, auch wenn ihr den Tarifvertrag oder
so, es sind alles Proto-Jahresgelder beziehungsweise Monatsgelder im Tarifvertrag, warum auch immer,
was für uns gut ist, weil bei uns gibt es 14 Monatsgelder, Steps Down Gehaltsbericht,
genau, da kannst du tatsächlich gucken, da kannst du sogar, die haben sogar so einen
Test, den du machen kannst, die haben sogar so einen Test, den man machen kann, wo du
Fragen beantworten musst, also zu deiner Person und dann sagen die, was es im Durchschnitt
so gibt, das ist aber natürlich drauf angelegt, du sollst dich da registrieren und bla und
sonst was, oh, Consulting, muss das jetzt sein, wirklich, Consulting, was, Überblick,
Proto-Durchschnittsgehalt, Personalverantwortung, ja, nein, Anzahl Mitarbeiter unterstellt,
aha, ok, ne, wir wollen, in welchem Bereich, gucken wir mal, zeig mal her, ehm, Gelder
von Fach- und Führungskräften, ja, schon ein Überblick, was guckt man da jetzt am
besten, ah, Branchen, Gehälter nach Branchen, Banken, also ich habe mir das ja alles nicht
ausgesucht, ja, aber ich stelle immer wieder fest, dass ich echt in einer guten Ecke gelandet
bin, also sowohl Frankfurt, sowohl Bank, als auch, sowohl was der Tarifvertrag hergibt,
als auch was am Ende noch rauskommt, obwohl ich nur Teilzeit arbeite, ich habe, es war
nie, ich habe es nie drauf angelegt, aber ich habe irgendwie echt Glück gehabt in der
Richtung, GG, ja, also so viel haben wir nicht, wobei ich mir ehrlich, nein, ich weiß es
nicht, das kann durchaus sein, dass wir über 1000 haben, wenn die ganzen Tochtergesellschaften
ungedönst mit dabei sind, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen Plassen Schimmer, also Gehälter
nach Bildungs, Abschluss, oh ja, da hast du schon, da hast du schon, ist schon mal nicht
verkehrt, gut, inwieweit das jetzt so ein Bachelor da was bringt, stimmt halt Null, naja,
auf wem der Grundlage wird das schon sein, dass es jetzt nicht auf den Einzelnen zutrifft,
ist ja auch klar, sowas ist ja immer über alle Sachen durch, ab 25 Jahren, ok, Berufserfahrung
25 Jahre, da brauche ich noch ein bisschen für, wer zählt als Akademiker, kein Schimmer,
das ist ja gerade die Frage hier, man erkennt es nicht wirklich, Top 5 Studienfächer, Medizin
und, Moment, was, Moment, dachte das wäre IT, ach Moment, das ist nicht nur IT, das
ist alles, für Führungs, ach Moment, wir haben voll den falschen Report, Alter, Zahntechnik,
was ab Seite 16, wo sieht man die Seitennummer, ah da unten, Seitennummern sind out, IT hier,
Crap, na gut, guck mal, mit was, was hast du hier, du hast Ärzte, Finanztons, Menschen,
irgendwelche Anwälte, Banking, Ingenieur, Unternehmensberater, Vertrieb, IT, Marketing,
ach ich bin ja immer froh, dass Marketing bei sowas relativ weit unten ist, Personal,
oh ja, jawoll, Marketing, Personal, PR, ganze Crap, der kann noch viel weiter runter, Naturwissenschaftliche
Forschung und Labor, ok, das dürfte ruhig weiter oben sein, ja, Einkauf, Logistik, na
gut, das ist im Lage hin und her fahren, Bildung, ja, dass das so schlecht bezahlt
wird, gerade Bildung sollte eigentlich besser bezahlt werden, Gesundheit und soziale Dienste,
das was alle brauchen wird am schlechtesten bezahlt, Design und Gestaltung, technische
Berufe, also mit technischen Berufe meinen sie jetzt in dem Fall nicht IT, sondern was
mit Holz zum Beispiel, so, die Gehälter für IT-Berufe im Überblick, achja, Protodurchschnittsgehalt,
ok, das ist, ja gut, das sagt jetzt für den Einzelnen nicht wirklich was aus, das Durchschnittsgehalt
ist wahrscheinlich viel höher als das was die meisten Leute kriegen, weil es halt wieder
ein paar gibt, die extrem viel bekommen, deswegen ist ja auch das Durchschnitts, das durchschnittliche,
wie nennt man das, Einkommen und sowas, was die Leute in Deutschland haben, insgesamt
ganz ok, wenn du aber mal guckst, wenn du mal so die allerreichsten weglässt, die
allerärmsten weglässt, dann ist es halt doch nicht so viel, und noch schlimmer ist, wenn
du die guckst, die Grenze zwischen Arm und Reich, wo die liegt, das ist viel niedriger
als man denkt, Hessen, komm mal, ich hab echt Glück gehabt, muss ich sagen, also ich mein,
was hatte ich eben gesagt, Bank, Bank, Hessen, Ulm, komm mal, eLotrix verdient 65.000, ähm,
ich hasse Ulm, Ulm sackt so hart, ich musste da jahrelang hinfahren, mag Ulm überhaupt
nicht, Moment, jetzt hab ich drüber gescrollt gerade, over IT, ja also, 65k, 53k, Geschlecht,
männlich, weiblich, Anteil variables Gehalt, 8%, mit Personalverantwortung 24, ok, und
in Hessen, tja, hast du eLotrix mal besucht, nein, warum sollte ich, wie viel meinst du
kriegt ein fachinformatischer Anwendungsentwickler nach der Ausbildung in Frankfurt, 40k, ja,
das geht schon, je nachdem wo du hinkommst, vielleicht sogar mehr, aber 40k in Frankfurt
als Einstiegsgehalt, als Anwendungsentwickler, wenn es jetzt nicht total die Klitsche ist,
ja, so, also, Moment, jetzt wollte ich doch jetzt mal gucken, gibt es jetzt irgendwie
noch nach, irgendwie Ausbildung, was man gelernt hat oder sonst was, ne, na gut, der
Gehaltsbericht, ok, ach hier kommt, Gehaltsunterschieden nach Aufgaben, Fälle, Berufserfahrung, IT-Architektur,
SAP, überall diese SAP-Crap, aber der verkauft sich gut, beziehungsweise er bringt gut Kohle,
Projektmanagement, IT-Beratung, ja, die von denen hatten wir es ja gerade am Anfang, Leute,
die den ganzen Tag heise Luft fabrizieren, zum größten Teil, nicht alle, aber zum größten
Teil sind die sehr gut im heise Luft fabrizieren, aber wirklich Ahnung haben sie nicht, Softwareentwicklung,
IT-Infrastruktur, Support, tja, da sieht man es mal, ne, Support wird meistens recht schlecht
bezahlt, Top-Berufstitel, IT-Manager, IT-Architekt, Softwarearchitekt, SAP-Inhouse-Consultant,
ist es dann, ist es einfach jemand, was ist ein Inhouse-Consultant, ist es einfach jemand,
der sich damit gut auskennt und dort angestellt ist, also quasi ein SAP-Experte, der dort
direkt angestellt ist, also ich mein, den könnte man auch anders nennen, den muss man
nicht SAP-Inhouse-Consultant nennen, aber das war's, ok, das war jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
aufschlussreich, Senior Software Engineer in, Moment, SAP-Inhouse-Consultantin, so geht's
ja nett, so geht's ja nett hier, so, hab ich eigentlich meinen Chat-Log eingeschmissen
hier, wo ist mein Chat-Log, ja das haben wir uns nicht gerade angeguckt gehabt, achso ja,
den Gehaltsplaner haben wir schonmal gemacht und die haben uns extrem krass gebaitet, erstens
hab ich weniger gekriegt laut Gehaltsplaner, als ich jetzt krieg und ich sollte mich danach
registrieren, dass er richtig funktioniert, was ist denn eine Cam-Programmiererin, das
hat wahrscheinlich nichts mit Webcam zu tun, oder, Nehradorn, Stufe 1, 12 Monate, excellent
Subscription, Dankeschön, Abortnetzwerk, Entwickler, Datenschutzkoordinator, CAD, Cam-Programmierer,
Networker, Integrations-Techniker, Nachrichtentechniker, der Name klingt so richtig oldschool, aber
richtig deutsch klingt der Nachrichtentechniker, Prüftechnik-Testkoordinator, Jobs für IT,
ok guck mal mal, 6 0 3 2 9, was haben die denn schönes, wir haben schon eine Weile nicht
mehr geguckt, da ist bestimmt wieder irgendwas drinnen, wo wir ein bisschen flamen können,
aber Praktikant, MV-Diverse, im Bereich Shopper, Shopper-Marketing, sind das Motorradfahrer,
Shopper-Marketing, Nestle, ok, ok, was wollen die denn von so einer Praktikant, ach guck
mal Bewertung, was ist mit der Mario Kart Musik los, warum wird hier auf einmal so laut,
und KS, Moment das ist die Lobby von Mario, ach exzellent, na na na na na das machen wir
jetzt nochmal, ok Nestle für ein Praktikant, ok bla bla bla, können wir alles einmal überspringen,
welche Rolle nehmen sie ein, im Shopper-Marketing, ah das sind die die einkaufen gehen, das sind
die Shopper, sie arbeiten als Kategorie übergreifende Schnittstellen strategisch mit
dem Markt, als Praktikant, als Praktikant, sie unterstützen im Rahmen der digitalen Shopper
Ansprache, was ist denn das für ein bescheuerter Satz, der ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, sie
unterstützen im Rahmen der digitalen Shopper Ansprache und entwickeln, was ist das für
ein Satz, der ergibt keinen Sinn, ich kann den Satz nicht mal richtig aussprechen, weil
ich immer denke da fehlen Wörter, sie unterstützen im Rahmen der digitalen Shopper Ansprache
und entwickeln digitale Kampagnen in Zusammenarbeit mit Startup, what, das ist Massive Stonks
Sprache und mal ganz davon abgesehen, als Praktikant, was soll ich für den Link öffnen?
Was war ich halt für ein Link, den Spider von Heise, ok warte mal, was ist denn das
eigentlich für eine, what, was ist das für eine Uhr, na gut war es auch immer, marktübliche
IT Geld, der Helpdesk und Support, gut das ist immer ganz unten sowas, ja leider, datenbank
administration, Netzwerk, Telekom, Softwareentwicklung, Beratung, IT Sicherheit, Management, ok,
Perzentil, wo bin ich, also früher hätte ich mich dazu gezählt, aber ich mache keine
Administration mehr, schon seit Jahren nicht mehr, da bin ich am ehesten, wobei, da bin
ich auch nicht, ich bin, mich gibt es nicht, was sind denn Perzentil, Prozent, also die
unteren 25% dann irgendwie, oder was wollen sie hier, und dann die oberen, die oberen
5%, irgendwie das sind die oberen 5%, das sind die unteren 25%, das ist so der Durchschnitt,
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ja das ist nicht so richtig, das hier finde ich, ich
will ein bisschen, ich will noch ein bisschen ablässern über Nestle, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich,
mal ganz im Ernst, die wollen doch nicht, dass das wirklich jemand umsonst macht oder,
ist das richtig, die wollen, dass das hier jemand umsonst macht, die müssen da schon
was für kriegen, ansonsten wäre das doch komplett affig, ja da muss es Geld für geben,
ansonsten wäre das doch, aber da steht halt nichts zu, da steht nichts von Gehalt, aber
wenn das wirklich kostenlos ist, dann wäre das echt, das ist ja geschenkt, naja, na gut,
was hat Nestle so für Bewertungen, leider bestenfalls Durchschnitt, relativ viel Pause,
im Normalfall kann man eher mal nach Hause gehen, also ich finde, dass Nestle sackt zum
größten Teil, hier guckt euch das mal an, stärken, pünktliche Gehaltszahlung, ok,
wenn das schon die Stärken sind, ich meine, pünktliche Gehaltszahlung ist keine Stärke,
pünktliche Gehaltszahlung ist die Basis, auf der man länger als einen Monat dahin zur Arbeit
geht, also ohne pünktliche Gehaltszahlung gibt es auch keine Arbeit, viele Zulangen,
Sommergeld, Weihnachtsgeld, Urlaubsgeld, ok, spontan freien, aber meist ohne Probleme
möglich, also mit Schichtsystem scheint das zu sacken, 10 Monate, Dankeschön, Subscription,
was wusste ich, das ist human, hier steht nix mit humaner Arbeit, kann man hier sortieren
nach, was ist das Unternehmen mit der schlechtesten Bewertung, ok, die Mario Kart Musik, die geht
mir auf den Keks, weil die ist unterschiedlich laut, wobei jetzt gehts eigentlich, hat sich
eingekrägt, ich muss noch was anderes machen, das hatten wir erst letztens, ah yes, excellent,
das ist schön entspannt, was neben der Suchleiste erweitert, Bewertung, ne kann man nicht, man
kann nicht nach Bewertung suchen, das wäre auch zu geil, ich wollte mal nach dem schlecht
bewerteten Unternehmen suchen, aber das geht anscheinend nicht, ok, schauen wir mal, was
haben die sonst noch schönes zu bieten gerade, also in Fragen von Nestle Praktika, ne das
muss nicht unbedingt sein, technischer Projektmanage für den Bereich Spritzguss, excellent, das
war es für den Chat, kannst du bei Kunden, was Kunden, habe ich denn, ok, ich will das
schlecht bewertete IT Unternehmen in Deutschland haben, kann man da nach, nach Branche suchen,
IT, hier alle Branchen, IT, und jetzt Bewertung, Bewertung absteigend, äh Bewertung aufsteigend,
kann man mindest, mindest, mindest Bewertung, weil, weil die kennt ja keiner hier, die sind
ja komplett, komplett unbekannt alle, die haben ja nicht mal Bilder, oh ja, die sacken
alle, heftig, die sacken hardcore, immer Bewertung absteigend, die haben auch alle kein Bild,
warum haben die alle kein Bild, ok, die Suche ist doof, ok, dann suchen wir nach, wer hat
die weißen Bewertungen, Anzahl Bewertungen, ja gibt es nicht, ah das ist ja doof, so schauen
wir mal, was haben die denn hier schönes, SAP, ja überall, überall ist es, was Bewertung
ab, ja ne, ab Sterne, aber ich will ja sagen, ab, wie viel abgegebener Bewertung, so was
haben die hier schönes noch für uns hier, ah wir gucken, ne, ne, ne Leute, wir gucken
mal wieder, wir gucken mal, was unser Lieblingsunternehmen in Frankfurt so treibt, wir müssen uns mal
wieder Telekom-Stellangebote angucken, die sind immer am lustigsten, was die da teilweise
für Buzzwords um sich, um sich hauen, Moment, das ist aber nicht das, was ich, was ich meinte
hier, Jobs, wir müssen uns wieder die Telekom angucken, ja genau, da sind wir, Deutschland,
ja Frankfurt, Frankfurt, auf, allein schon, wie bescheuert man hier rein scrollen muss,
ja das ist das Interessante in Frankfurt, da, da, in der Ecke, Niederrad, ne, ne, doch
nicht, da, exzellent, was, was, was will ich hier, Bachelor, Fachinformatiker, das sind
Ausbildungsstellen, sowas in der Richtung, oder, weil niemand sucht ein Fachinformatiker
Systementwicklung, das ist Ausbildungsstellen, Werkstudent, Ausbildungsstellen oder irgendwie
sowas, die Seite ruckelt übrigens, Head of Competence Sender, IT-Industry, what, Hunter,
ein Hunter suchen die, von KS, ja, ok, Telekom sucht gerade nix, aber die Telekom sucht Azubis,
die weiß man, wie man sich eigentlich nennen kann, kommt auch an, was du dich bewerbst,
wenn du Fachinformatiker Systementwicklung gelernt hast, danach sucht keiner, du musst
halt irgendwas suchen, dann was zu deinem Kenntnisstand entspricht, von Softwareentwicklung
bis Administration, bis Automatisierungsgeschichten, bis Cloud, bis sonst was, was halt passt
zu dem was du kannst, was ist das denn, Taze, was ist das denn, zeig mal her, oh, excellent,
das sieht das, was ist das bei der Polizei Hessen, das, also diese Seite sieht aus wie
von 1992, wer das auch immer erstellt hat, weiß ich auch nicht, aber einen Vorteil hat's,
man kann's relativ gut lesen, E13, heute E13 gab's doch kaum Geld, oder, wir hatten das
ja schon mal geguckt, E13, E13 gibt's doch kein Geld für, E13, E13, was ist das Stufe
3, Stufe 4, okay, keine Ahnung, wollen die mich verarschen, ach Moment, netto bleiben,
netto bleiben, okay, okay Moment, ich hab nix gesagt, das sind ja die einzigen, die
das in netto machen, oh ja, oh ja, so schlecht ist das doch gar, was ist denn, was ist denn
Klasse 1, sind das Berufsjahre oder sowas, morgen KS, ist doch ordentlich, ich hab leider
keine Ahnung, was diese Stufen hier unten sind, Stufe 1, 1 Jahr, Stufe 2, 2 Jahr, also
das heißt Stufe 6, wir sind irgendwie nach 20 Jahren oder so, okay, dann gehen wir mal
was von halbwegs realistisch, ach so, wie ist das eigentlich, wird das einem angerechnet,
also mal angenommen theoretisch, jemand hat jetzt wie ich seit 2007, schon quasi Berufserfahrung,
seit 13 Jahren, wird das dann angerechnet, wenn das nicht angerechnet wird, was ja Blödsinn,
schau dir mal die Schweizer, das bringt nix zu vergleichen, das geht doch halbwegs, also
ich mein das ist jetzt nix wo ich sagen würde, ich muss sofort hier dahin, aber das sieht
doch schon mal ganz okay aus, okay was schreiben sie, was suchen sie überhaupt, eine Informatikerin,
eine Informatikers im Bereich, warum suchen die keinen Informatikkorps, im Bereich Kriminaltechnik,
auch richtige Hackermans suchen die, in Vollzeit, die Eingruppierung erfolgt, Moment, da gibt
es auch noch so andere Abstufungen, Moment, das ist das was wir gerade schon hatten, das
ist das was wir gerade schon hatten, also passt, passt, das kremen, bla, bla, bla, bla,
die Aufgabengebiet umfasst die Gewährleistungsbetrieb der KTI, jetzt, okay, Entwicklung von speziellen
IT-Lösungen hin und Erstellung von IT, für das, was ist denn das, Kriminaltechnische
Institut, okay, Abkürzung, Abkürzung immer gut, bla, bla, bla, okay, da muss man aber
schon von dem Thema Ahnung haben, also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, was die genau wollen
mit mobiler IT-Verfahren zu Analyse und Rekonstruktion von Tatordnen, sollst du Festplatten entschlüsseln
oder wie?
Was ist aus dem Projekt mit Traffic geworden, hat alles funktioniert, ja, Leitung von Projekten
zur Einführung von IT-Anwendung, Datenbank, okay, ich mein, das könnte man vielleicht
auch in den Titel schreiben, weil Projektleiter ist ja nun mal ein bisschen was anderes als
einfach Hacker-Man, Planung, Beschaffung in Betriebnahme von IT, Moment, die wollen
einen Projektleiter und gleichzeitig einen, der ein Computer anschließt, seh ich das
richtig?
Das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen, technische Analyse und gegebenenfalls Beseitigung von
Microsoft, okay, Gewährleistung der Umsetzung, für die Landesverwaltung, Geld in der IT-Sicherheit,
bla, bla, bla, bla, okay, Mitarbeiter in Gremien, ja, okay, also ich könnte das mit den meisten
Sachen gar nicht so wirklich was sagen, anfangen, oder vergleichbar, gute Kenntnisse in der
Entwicklung und Pflege von rationalen Datenbanken, Microsoft SQL Software, Weiche, der Teufel,
Oscar als Beste, Kenntnis und Erfahrung im IT-Projektmanagement, also ich find das,
also das liest sich alles ganz okay, aber das meiste liest sich halt wie so ein ganz
klassischer Turnschuh-Admin, der halt unterwegs ist und guckt, dass alles funktioniert und
das liest sich nicht nach einem Projektmanager, ausgeprägt, ja, bla, bla, Herr Doktor Aalhorn,
hoffentlich lässt er nicht den Aal raus, aber das war schlecht, ich geb's zu, Aalhorn,
alles klar, ja, gut, ich muss euch, es liest sich gar nicht so schlecht, aber ich kann mir
wenig darunter vorstellen, muss ich auch gestehen, Hanfollow ist raus, so, also genau, die Telekom
sucht Azubis und die suchen die überhaupt eine Ausbildung, ja, Ausbildung, boah, was
man als Azubi mittlerweile kriegt ist ja heftig, na gut, bei mir ist das ja auch schon ewig
her, selbst wenn du einfach jedes Jahr ein bisschen was drauf haust, bist du dabei jetzt
schon, ja, naja, bei mir ist das irgendwie 15 Jahre her ungefähr und wenn du dann irgendwie
pro Jahr nur 2-3% drauf haust, bist ja schon bei dem Gehalt, also im Prinzip ist da eigentlich
gar nichts gegen zu sagen, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, es ist Frankfurt, Frankfurt ist
immer teuer, stories, nachdem Khaled Deutsch gelernt hat, lernt er jetzt seinen Traumberuf,
hä, was hat das mit der Stellenanzeige zu tun, Khaled kommt aus Syrien und muss erst
Deutsch lernen, bevor er seine Ausbildung zum fachinformatischen Systemenintegration
beginnen konnte, er liebt es jeden Tag etwas neu, ok, die Telekom möchte sich als besonders
inclusive darstellen, verstehe, das ist ja gerade aktuell im Trend, ähm, ich bin begeistert
von seinem Kind, er sagt, sowohl in der Schule als auch im Ausbildungsbetrieb sind wir ein
gutes Team, ah ja, wo ist Khaled, ach, da gibt es wenigstens ein Bildchen zu, wie er
den Server einbaut oder sowas, exellent, Agile Coach, das ist was für mich, der Agile Coach,
jawoll, ich wollte schon immer agil bei der Telekom sein, was geht hier ab, Agile Coach,
so, so, also, ok, sie kreieren in der Organisation den nötigen Rückenwind auf unserem Weg in
die Zukunft, als Agile Coach mit in der Praxis gefestigten Methodenkompetenz, was zum Geier
soll das überhaupt bedeuten, mit Herzblut, ok, das ist ja auch nichts für mich, was
heißt das überhaupt, mit Herzblut arbeiten sie an den folgenden Themen, sie ergänzen
das schon bestehende Agile Chapter Team, das sich mit der Vereinfachung von Prozessen beschäftigt,
sowohl das Thema Time to Market als Fokus hat, also sprich, wie schnell kommt was raus,
sie gestalten aktiv den Weg der Weiterbindung für das Agile Chapter, das liest sich heftig
Bates Jam, Alter, sie fördern die Entwicklung eines Agilen Mindsets, vermitteln agile Werte
und Praktiken und treiben die kontinuierliche Agile Kompetenzentwicklung voran, ok, und
jetzt nochmal auf Deutsch, was macht man da genau, durch die Unterstützung und Schulde
von Agile Methodenkompetenz befähigen sie die Teams dazu diese Methoden dauerhaft nachhaltig
anzuwenden, ihre Stakeholder sind Tribe Leader, ok, ja, ich hab die Begriffe alle schonmal
irgendwie gehört, aber ich hab noch nie so viel in kurze, so viel zusammen komprimiert
gelesen auf einem Flag, also ihre Stakeholder sind Tribe Leader, also bei Scrum ist es so,
dass unterschiedliche Gruppen, die unterschiedliche Themen bearbeiten sind Tribes, warum man es
sich Gruppen nennt, weiß ich nicht, weil es cooler klingt, also wenn du die erste Gruppe
hast, die sich mit Thema A beschäftigt und die zweite Gruppe, die sich mit Thema B beschäftigt,
da könnte man das Gruppen nennen, in Scrum sind es aber nicht, sondern es sind Tribes,
weil Stonksmännchen das geiler finden, wenn das so heißt, dass man das nicht versteht,
es sind eigentlich Gruppen, Gruppenleiter sind das, Gruppenleiter im Endeffekt und die
hier halten, was machen wenn die Veganer sind, Painschamp, Management und Führungskräfte
sowie Mitarbeiter sampler Hierarchie imnen, Stakeholder sind im Prinzip, die es zu verantworten
haben, oder die da irgendwie mit drinne hängen, wie kann man das am besten beschreiben, wie
kann man am besten Stakeholder beschreiben, Stonks Chat, ihr kennt euch mit sowas aus,
BWL kram ich nicht, was genau ist die Definition von einem Stakeholder, Person, für die es
aufgrund ihrer Interessensanlage von Belangen ist, wie ein bestimmtes Unternehmen sich verhält,
Teilhaber, ah ok, Investoren, aber in dem Fall sind es ja gar keine Investoren,
ich hätte ja auch gesagt, da sind die, die es verantworten müssen in dem Fall und deswegen
halt auch Interesse daran haben, gut was auch immer, sie sind Vorreiter, die Yoshi Musik
passt da ganz gut zu, sonst wirst du hier komplett verrückt, ok, also sie sind Vorreiter und Botschafter
in der Agilisierung, was ein Wort, Agilisierung, Agilisation und eine Persönlichkeit, deren
Fokus auf People-Business liegt, aktuell ist People-Business aber schlecht, ok, was für
eine Zertifizierung brauche ich da, Zertifizierung Agile Coach, weiter Bildung zum Zertifizieren
Agile, so eine Scheiße gibt es echt, mein Gott das ist, dieser ganze Bullshit ist einfach
nur dazu da, um so einen Geldkreislauf zu generieren, genauso wie dieses ganze ISO,
DIN ISO 9001, ITIL, sonstigen Geschiss, Zertifizierungsgedöns, das ist einfach nur da, um so einen Geldfluss
zu generieren, das sich selbst mit Geld versorgt, ich will nicht sagen, dass es bei den einzelnen
Modellen nicht sinnvolle Sachen gibt, darum geht es gar nicht, klar, hier steht in ITIL
auch sinnvolle Sachen drinne, aber dieses ganze Geschäft, was da drumherum gemacht wird,
ist einfach, dass sich das ganze System selbst mit Geld versorgt, Scrum an sich ist super,
die meisten machen es nicht richtig, genau, die meisten stellen sich mit 15 Leuten hin,
labern 45 Minuten jeden Tag, setzen sich nicht dabei hin und sagen wir machen Scrum und
wenn du sie fragst, ok, was war jetzt hier dran Scrum, ja, weil wir uns nicht hingesetzt
haben, so, normalerweise muss das viel kürzer sein und es muss vor allem auch etabliert
werden, dass es ok ist, wenn man nichts sagt, ok, bla bla bla, Ausbildung und die langjährige
praktische Erfahrung in positiver Psychologie, Big Brain, Alter, jetzt geht es ab und systemischen
Business Coaching oder vergleichbar wie NLP Master, was zur Teufel ist das, NLP Practitioner
Certificate, es gibt in diesem Bereich so unglaublich viel Scheiße einfach, nur das ist der Wahnsinn,
mindestens 5 Jahre umfassen theoretisches und praktisches Wissen zu den Frameworks,
Scrum, was sonst, was sonst, also komm, mit Zertifizierung mindestens ACSM und CSP, SM
ist Scrum Master, denke ich mal und SAFE, dass das sagt, ich weiß jetzt nicht wovür es steht,
aber das sagt mir irgendwas, SAFE, Scaled Agile Framework, genau, sowie über OKRs und
Kanban, ok, ich kann eine Tabelle hin und her schieben, von Technologischen Crew, ach
du Scheiße, was ein Geschwätze, boah, da kriegst du ja Anfälle, wenn du das liest, ey, Benefits,
Teilzeit, wie du das in Teilzeit machen willst, bin ich mal gespannt, Plexible Weiterbildung
angeboten, ach du große 9er, meine Güte, die Telekom, Agile Coach, Elsa sagt, habe
die Woche auch eine Stelle mit 10 Jahre Go Erfahrung gesehen, oh 10 Jahre Go ist nicht
schlecht, Go ist ja mit 8 und gerade mal 10 Jahre alt, am besten ist man noch der Entwickler,
genau, man hat es erfunden, jolle gebe ich ja recht, denke ich, wie der größte Schwachsinn
überhaupt, ja, ok, in Frankfurt suchen die anscheinend nichts, da kann man nichts machen,
wenn die Telekom nichts sucht, kann man es heute nicht auslassen über die Telekom, Schüler,
Studenten, Absolventen, Professionals, ok, Professionals, wir sind Professionals, hast
du schon Agile im Korea TTS, nee, ihre Karriere als Professional, Experten, ok, ich bin Experten,
zeig mal her, was empfiehlt mir die Telekom, Auslass, gehen wir fort, ihr könnt mich einfach
in Ruhe meine Arbeit machen lassen und mir nicht auf den Sack gehen, wer will denn so
was, ok, das ist so eine typische Sache, wenn das jemand will und er Bock drauf hat, ist
es gut, dass es das gibt und dann ist es auch schön, dass er das machen kann, aber aus
meiner Erfahrung sind die meisten IT Leute jetzt nicht so die extrovertiertesten Auslandsreise-Fans,
um es mal vorsichtig auszudrücken, also die meisten haben schlichtweg keinen Bock drauf
und ich handele mich auch so, lasst mich doch einfach meine Arbeit machen, geht mir nicht
mit zig Bullshit zwischendurch auf den Sack, lasst mich doch einfach meine Arbeit machen
und gut ist, Karrierefahrt, ok, Inhouse Consulting, schau mir da, es ist übrigens toll, dass man
als Consultant anfängt, also sprich man fängt als Consultant an, also sprich man soll konsultiert
werden zu Problemen und man hat vorher keine Ahnung, also normalerweise müssten hier eigentlich
noch ein paar Schritte davor kommen, so nach dem Motto ok, know how, ich werde Consultant
da drinnen, aber nein, ich fange als Consultant an, also ich habe keinen Plan und fange schon
mal als Consultant an, genau diesen Eindruck habe ich von unseren Consultants auch, ne,
geh fort, geh fort, ja, Junior Consultant, genau, wie gesagt, unser Spezialer Zubi ist
auch Junior Consultant geworden und da konnte mir in seiner Fachinformatik Ausbildung, der
hat einen halben Nervenzusammenbruch gekriegt, wo ich ihn nach Netzwerkgrundlagen gefragt
habe und so jemand wird Junior Consultant, was ist, was hast du mir da für Link geschickt,
was hast du mir da geschickt, was hast du mir da geschickt, was hast du mir da geschickt,
Wir suchen mal nach
Das könnte man mal suchen
Ne wir machen mal was anderes
Wir machen mal was anderes wir gucken mal nach was ganz klassischem
Wir gucken mal nach einem administrator nach was ganz klassischem
administration in frankfurt was ganz ganz klassisches
Und mal gucken ob es da irgendwas gescheites gibt
Hier ist der devops cloud engineer am start
Was ganz klassisch okay sachbearbeiter administration
Administrator
Hier sollten wir lieber danach suchen
Ein kubanetes administrator adesso as a service
Ich ich ich ahne ich ahne
buzzwords
Und eine sache die mir bei diesen ganzen stellenanzeigen immer nicht einleuchtend ist
Warum übertreiben warum müssen die am anfang immer so eine riesen
Abgesangen auf oder so eine riesen lobes hymne auf sich selbst anstimmen
Das interessiert doch denjenigen der das jetzt hier grad zum ersten mal liest nicht die bohne
die sollten zum beispiel ganz die sollten vielleicht
Ganz oben hinschreiben gehalsspanne oder sowas das wäre interessant
Kuba netes administrator mit begeisterung für infraschung und applikation zur begebung
Kein blabla sie haben erste praktik als system engineer oder application administrator in projekten mit kubanetes oder einer container plattform gesammelt
Begeistert sich für aktuelle cloud plattform technologien sind bereit den defops und seit
reliability engineering ansatz tatkräftig zu unterstützen und eng mit ja
Dann sind sie bei uns genau richtig
Diese formulierung die haben sie doch aus irgendeinem buch oder
weil man mal ehrlich ist niemand
Geht auf eine bewerbung seite und sagt ich würde mir so gern wünschen
dass ich ein begeistert dass ich dass ich begeistert dass ich mich begeistert also dass ich ein begeisterter
Aktuell begeben für aktuelle cloud plattform und technologien und ich würde auch so gern defops und seit
reliability engineering tatkräftig unterstützen
Sagt halt keiner das sind sie bei uns genau richtig sie werden teil eines dynamischen teams und helfen mit systemlandschaft unserer kunden
zu konzipieren aufzubauen
Und das ist ja alles ok das klingt aber wirklich sehr vorlagen mäßig wie sie das geschrieben haben wir hatten letztens ein paar richtig coole stellen anzeigen
Ich weiß nicht mehr wo das war die waren wirklich
Mit brain geschrieben ja also sprich wurde auch was hat es davon wenn du nie gelesen hast
Unterstützung bei der vorbereitung von java software artefakten für die
Geht schon gut los hier? Das ist java
Es fängt schon mal gut an
Dekonikation verteilen von in helm charts
Das ist ja voll angesagt ich wusste gar nicht dass das charts hat
Helm charts
Ach das ist eine extra geschichte für mit charts dafür oder was
Wie gesagt ich wusste nicht dass das das das das das das charts hat
Ok exzellent charts
Deklaration von infrastruktur komponenten terraform terraform ist voll angesagt aktuell
Für aws azure und vmw sphär boar die wollen es aber wissen azure und aws und noch ein bisschen vmw
Testen und ausrollen neue software
Stände in enger zusammenarbeit mit teams aus entwicklung. Es ist alles vollkommen ok was die hier wollen ja
Wobei man sagen muss so rein klassische administration ist es jetzt ja nicht
Unterstützung bei der entwicklung von betriebsunterstützenden containern ja ok
Das ist alles das ist alles in ordnung. Ja ok ihre skills
Erfolgreich abgeschleunigt ok immer immer immer das gleiche gute linux und bs
Jetzt jetzt gehen sie aber in die vollen hier
Mit bsd kenntnissen wirst du nicht so viele leute finden das kann ich das kann ich euch sagen also
Gut aber kenntnisse sind ja bei manchen leuten auch schon
also wir hatten mal einen der hat gesagt er ist fortgeschritten in also fortgeschrittene kenntnisse in vmw
Und als wir den gefragt haben was er gemacht hat hat er gemeine ubuntu vm installiert jetzt kein witz klingt so als hätte ich es
mehr ausgedacht ich weiß aber das war das warum er fortgeschrittene kenntnisse in vmw hatte
Grundlegendes verständnis von
Netzwerk protokollen und architekturen tcp ip mpls
Und architekturen tcp ip mpls
Peering hab und
Ok dabei wer ist bei mir schon mal raus was ist hab end spoke
spoke nabespeiche was
Äh
Was
Ok ab und spoke alles klar
Ich mein es ist es ist es angeblich ist netzwerk protokoll beziehungsweise netzwerk infrastruktur aber netzwerk architektur
Ich habe ernsthaft keine ahnung was damit gemeint ist
Vielleicht wollen die mir damit sagen wie man am besten
Netzwerkgeräte miteinander
Verbindet und beziehungsweise wie man das am besten von der architektur her aufbaut dass es ordentlich läuft
Pro gaming sebi schreibt wenn ich kann das einfach zeigen
Kubernetes oder docker möchte mir über den sommer eins vielleicht beides anschauen die frage stellt sich gar nicht docker
Wenn du wenn du von du wirst du wirst gehoffnungslos gegen die wand fahren wenn du irgendwie was kubernetes mäßig machen möchtest wenn du nicht
Ein, bisschen linux container grundlagen hast und da ist docker nun mal das das ding was sich durchgesetzt hat
Also das da musst du machen das da und dann später kannst du dir vielleicht ein bisschen das da angucken aber das da
Also docker ist für den heimbereich auch um größten ordnung sinnvoller als docker
Es ist ja gar nicht entweder oder
Docker ist für lokal ein bisschen container laufen lassen vielleicht mit docker kompost ein bisschen
Bis ein bisschen das managen und kubernetes ist eher so orchestrierungsgeschichte von container also die frage ist gar nicht entweder oder
Sondern in deinem fall wenn du sagst was du lernen sollst docker ganz klar das da zuerst und danach das
Hast du das schon gesehen
Ne was ist das
Mir d rocket kill nicht yummy
Moment, die, die, die lassen ihr JavaScript von, von Web Archive Org aus liefern?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Das ist ja Big Brain, dann spart man sich Traffic.
Das ist, das ist ja, dass da nicht noch schon mehr drauf gekommen sind.
Das ist Big Brain, was ist das für Traffic?
Das muss man sich sparen, Alter.
Der Support checkt's nicht.
Ah, okay, okay.
Okay, jetzt hast du auch gecheckt, alles klar.
Das ist ja toll.
Lustig.
Nice.
Ähm, okay, das liest sich alles, das liest sich alles relativ normal, was die hier haben
wollen.
Auch keine komischen Sachen zwischendrin, dass du noch Projektmanagement und First-Level-Support
mitmachen sollst, wie bei anderen Sachen.
Leute, in drei Wochen hab ich meinen Azure DevOps Fünf-Tage-Kurs, ja?
Und danach bin ich, äh, abgecradet, der Hacker-Mann.
Oh guck mal, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung reicht nicht mehr.
Die brauchen Zwölf-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Ja, der AZ-900 ist übelst Resident-Sleeper gewesen und ich geh davon aus, dass der DevOps-Kurs
auch Mega-Resident-Sleeper wäre, wird.
Ich weiß, dass damit nicht Zwölf-Faktor-Authentifizierung gemeint ist, aber es liest sich wie Zwölf-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
oder?
Ja, jetzt hier, Big-Big-Brain, was wollen sie hier haben?
Der Karton-Plast, was, die Karton-Plast-Gruppeier, ok, also, das erwartet sie, First- und Second-Level-Anwendungssupport,
ok, Instant-Range-Quit, Winners 10 Office 356 Drucker, die werden, oh Gott, Instant-Range-Quit,
Second-Kundensupport, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Leute, äh, wie viele Stunden arbeitest
du die Woche?
Das ist eine gute Frage, ich kann's dir nicht sagen, also, äh, irgendwie siebeneinhalb Stunden
oder so am Tag, siebeneinhalb Stunden mal vier, mal sieben mal vier, 30, irgendwie keine Ahnung,
32 Stunden oder so, 30 Stunden, irgendwie so, 30 Stunden, arbeite ich.
Ok, die suchen wirklich, das finde ich cool, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt, die suchen
wirklich so den ganz klassischen Drucker-Anschließer, Kleines, also Drucker scheinen sehr wichtig
zu sein, weil Drucker haben die sogar zweimal drin stehen.
Ach, und nebenbei machst du noch Monitoring der gesamten IT-Infrastruktur, alles klar.
Ok, geht doch.
Wie hast du die 30 Stunden verhandelt, Kondition gleichgeblieben, äh, naja, ich krieg weniger
Geld, weil ich anstatt 38 Stunden oder so nur noch 30 Stunden arbeite, naja, klar,
dass ich nie die gleiche Kohle krieg wie vorher, ist ja klar, wenn, wäre natürlich noch viel
besser, ja, aber es ist nicht so, aber ansonsten hat sich nix geändert, genau das gleiche,
bloß einfach weniger Stunden, die Z-Bank, was wollen die, was, was ist, was ist F-C-S-I,
Ach, das heißt so bei denen, ok, First- und Second-Level-Support im Rahmen F-C-S-I, Administration
mit Admin Gui und Saga, die erwarten doch nicht ernsthaft, dass irgendjemand, was ist
das, Server, Age of Conan, alles klar, die erwarten doch nicht immer, dass das jemand
kennt, Planung und Umsetzung der System-Release-Wechsel, technische Beratung bei RT, Strukturfragen,
Analyse-Optimierung, das liest sich alles, heute ist wenig Trash dabei, also das liest
sich alles relativ realistisch, ja, aber wir müssen eher bei den krassen Start-ups gucken,
oh je, oh je, das ist ein Bullshit-Shop, das sieht man sofort schon, gar nicht mal von
der Beschreibung her, aber Admin Mann im Krankenhaus, ich glaube da hast du keinen Spaß, bist umgeben
von technisch unfähigen Leuten wahrscheinlich und es ist auch noch wichtig, was du machst,
sonst kratzen Leute ab, das würde ich mir nicht geben und es wird wahrscheinlich auch
noch schlecht bezahlt, also das würde ich mir nicht geben, in Offenbach, ob da Haftbefehlt
schonmal drin gewesen ist, ok, was macht man hier, sicherstellen des User-Supports, ok,
die wollen einen, der alles macht, ich sehe schon, Administration der Rechner und Server-Systeme
sicherstellen des User-Supports bezüglich Hardware-Betriebssystems, Office-Umfeld, Meld-Line,
boah, fuck, du musst ja echt alles machen, Planung, Durchführung, Verwaltung, regelmäßiger
Backup, Beschaffung, Konfiguration, Installation, Neuer, ok, du machst alles, du machst alles
IT, du machst komplett alles IT, so wie es aussieht, Betreuung, Installation von Software
und systemnahe, was, Betreuung von Installation von Software und systemnahe Software, Überwachung
und Portikulierung der Funktionsfähigkeit der Server und der aktiven Netz, Ach, Netzwerk-Infrastruktur
machst du auch noch mit, Beseitigung aufgetretener Störungen gemeinsam mit Soft- und Hardware-Lieferanten,
auch noch, Überwachung und Wartung der passiven Netzwerk, Netzwerk-Monitoring machst du auch
noch, verstehe, Betreuung, Wartung, Austausch und Neueinsatz, Ach, Endkundensupport und Aufbau
der Arbeitsplätze machst du auch noch, Unterstützung der Anwender bei Softwarenutzung, also Support
und Office erklären auch noch, Pflege, die Homepage machst du auch noch, Benutzer und
E-Mail-Kontenverwahl, ok, Mail-Administrator machst du auch noch, Eigenverantwortliche
Erstellung von firmenspezifischen Auswertungen, what the fuck, was soll denn das geben, wenn
es fertig ist, also ja, das kann alles ein Administrator machen, aber das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen viel für einen Administrator, was hat der 400 Wochenstunden oder was, ok,
also was wollen sie haben, gute Kenntnis im Bereich der Windows-Betriebsstelle, da bin
ich schon mal raus, da bin ich schon mal raus, also nicht, dass ich das jemals freiwillig
machen würde, dazu müsste ich irgendeine Straftat begehen und zu gemeinnütziger Arbeit
verurteilt werden und das Gericht müsste irgendwie anordnen, dass ich das machen muss,
damit ich das machen würde, unter Androhung von Knast, sonst würde ich das nicht machen,
das würde ich lebendig machen hier, Kenntnisse im Netzwerkbereich, TCP-IP, Warn-Lan-VPN,
Eigenverjagte, Bereitschaft zu teamorientierter Arbeitsstil, wieso teamorientierter Arbeitsstil,
du machst doch alles selbst, welches Team, du brauchst ja noch kein Team mehr, du machst
doch alles, Erfahrung mit Datenbanken auch noch, das ist ein Ger, das muss ich mir in
den Kopf machen, das ist was, was ich flamen kann, sehr gute Deutschkenntnisse, Diskretion
und Loyalität, das ist zu einem gewissen Grad kaufbar, würde ich mal behaupten, also sprich,
wenn das Gehalt gut ist, dann ist Diskretion und Loyalität sicherlich auch gut, wenn das
Gehalt ein Apel und ein Ei ist, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es manche mit Diskretion
und Loyalität nicht so ernst nehmen, Einsatzbereitschaft, Motivation, Flexibilität im Aufgabenbereich,
das heißt, du darfst doch ab und zu mal die OP, den OP-Tisch putzen oder wie, Grundeinstellung
zur nächsten Ebe und mittragen, mittragen, mittragen, mittragen, mittragen, mittragen,
mittragen, michael 50 Billiardenbeutel, mittragen viel besser, unseres Leitbildes, was ist denn
euer Leitbild, Leitbild, steht nirgendwo, was euer Leitbild ist, was ist denn euer Leitbild,
Grundeinstellung zur nächsten Ebe, Leute wisst ihr was, ich finde diese drei Worte, ich finde
die wirklich gut, also sowas könnten die gerne mehr auch noch bei anderen Stellenanzeigen
irgendwie reinpacken, ich finde eine Grundeinstellung zur nächsten Ebe finde ich nicht verkehrt,
ich meine gut klar hier geht es ums Krankenhaus oder so, aber das ist ein Job, den ich im
Leben nicht machen würde, aber diese drei Worte, die kommen hier finde ich eigentlich
nicht schlecht, diese Einstellungen sollten mehr Leute haben, der Q-Chat, genau, so wir
bieten, Leistungsgerechte Vergütung nach dem gültigen Tarifvertrag AVR, ja, welche Stufe,
welche was, Tarifvertrag AVR, gucken wir mal, what the fuck, was, ja welches davon ist es,
Mitarbeiter im Pflegedienst, aber das ist doch kein Pflegedienst, äh, drei, what the fuck,
was ist das für ein Rechner, das ist doch kein Gehaltsrechner, das ist eine fertige
Tabelle, zum Rechner, Hessen, wo ist Hessen, Alter wer hat diese Seite wieder gemacht,
ich mache jetzt einfach mal das da auf, ist egal, Geburtsjahr, ok, 1984, was weiß ich,
ok, das kann ich nicht ausrechnen, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, wir bieten Feld wirklich
sehr, ähm, zurückhaltend aus, ja, ich meine sie bieten Geld, das ist ja schonmal die Grundvoraussetzung
dafür, dass man da überhaupt jemand dran denkt, da zu arbeiten, dass sie, ja, regelmäßig
freundlich und kollegial ist, da habe ich so meine Zweifel, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass da ziemlich oft Stress und dicke Luft ist, das ist Krankenhaus, da willst du nicht
arbeiten, ihre Aussage kräftige Bewerber, das ist so ein Ding, wo es mir irgendwie in
den Fingern juckt, einfach mal zu fragen, was es für Geld gibt, das interessiert mich
brennend, was es da für Geld gibt, das Problem ist, ich kann da nicht einfach fragen, wobei
warum eigentlich nicht, wie gesagt, ich will es auf keinen Fall machen, mich interessiert
aber echt einfach mal, was es da für gibt, ich könnte wetten, es gibt nichts, es gibt
irgendwie 30k im Jahr oder so, es wird wahrscheinlich nichts, das Punkt mag ich mir mal, ich glaube,
ich schreibe da echt mal eine E-Mail hin, was es da, was es da so für Gehaltsaussichten
gibt, wahrscheinlich 25k oder sowas, na ich kann mich da nicht bewerben, da müsste bewerbung
schreiben, ich glaube es geht los, außerdem will ich mich da gar nicht bewerben, ich will
einfach mal, hast du schon mal die Website, ok, die gucken wir uns jetzt an, Cat Tiller
Krankenhaus, Offenbach, oh Schlaflabor, 1995 klopft an,
1995 guckt vorbei, will seine Website wieder haben, eine Babygalerie haben sie, immerhin,
immer edlische Babys, aber das ist wirklich 1995, hat angeklopft und will die Website
wieder haben, Internationalpatient, ok, ich muss erstmal ranzoomen, ok, jetzt wisst ihr
auch, warum die jemand suchen, die sich um den Web auftritt, das Internet, warum die
jemand suchen, der sich um die Website kümmert, oh das Leitbild, das ist ja das, was wir wissen
wollten, oh da gibt es ein Video zu, liebe Lindert Leiden, man darf nicht mal spulen,
what the fuck, ah, spulen, nicht erlaubt, denied, ok, das muss man jetzt nicht geben,
was ist denn die Babygalerie, naja wahrscheinlich neu geborene Babys, die da im Krankenhaus
auf die Welt gekommen sind oder so, spulen und gleich Nächstenliebe, das stimmt, ich
finde ein bisschen mehr Nächstenliebe beim Videoplayer hätte nicht verkehrt geschadet,
ok, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr flamen, weil die haben kein Budget, die kriegen auch kein
Budget, die sind wahrscheinlich komplett am Limit, die haben, die kommen nicht hinterher
und die brauchen irgendeinen, der sich um die IT kümmert und haben keine Geld, ihn
zu bezahlen, wofür sie auch nicht so wirklich was können, also mich interessiert echt brennend,
was man da kriegt, ich glaube ich frag die einfach mal, ich glaube ich schreibe da einfach
mal eine Mail hin, was mich interessieren würde, was man da so bekommt, ob das noch
im Tarif hat, welche Stufe man bekommen könnte, das würde mich echt interessieren, weil
ich wette, ich könnte wetten, das ist saumäßig wenig, 30k, 25k oder sowas, was letzte Preis
schreibe ich dann in die Mail rein, genau, was letzte Gehalt, ja, 25k nicht bisschen
arg wenig, doch, natürlich ist das arg wenig, aber ich glaube es wird arg wenig sein, die
nicht augen klinik, aha, ja gut, das passt ja schon mal dazu, oder, guck mal, Hyper-V
machen die, fundierte Kenntnis im Bereich, das ist wieder irgendwas, was die Personalfrau
geschrieben hat und man ihr gesagt hat, schreibe das rein, ja, plopsrusher, ich hab irgendwas
gesagt, was halt wenig ist, es ist wahrscheinlich unglaublich wenig, was du kriegst, deswegen
interessiert es mich ja auch, noch mehr, SAP, SAP, jetzt hört er gar nicht mehr auf, SAP,
der Wetteraukreis, Moment, da war jemand mit dem Feuerlöcher, nee, das ist was ganz
was anderes, Moment, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, ja, it's public administration, zu
viel SAP überall, soll ich eine Mail schreiben, wenn du willst, ja, das kannst du dir überlegen,
ob du das machst, ich stifte keinen dazu an, die irgendwie zuzuspermen jetzt, nicht dass
du es dir mit dem Kettler Krankenhaus verscherzt, ich schreibe ja nicht alle ihr Spasten was
letztes Gehalt, schreibe da eine ganz normale Mail hin, wie soll ich mir da mit denen verscherzen,
so plus line, von denen hab ich schonmal was gehört, ich glaub die machen bei uns irgendwas,
manage services, ich glaub die managen irgendwas für uns, blablabla, mit einem echten Interesse
für Linux und Open Source, ok, das wäre ja schonmal was für mich, wenn sie mit der Kommando
Zeile an und dem Editor bereits sicher umgehen können, exellent, sie suchen jemand wie, für
apache MySQL Postfix, wir machen sie vertraut mit o-wirt, kvm, da fehlt ein Komma, vmwir,
kvmstack, sie nutzen aktuellste wie Puppet Ansible, Ichinga, nein ich mag oldschool Nagios,
Nagios beste, Grafana, Elastic Search, Logstash, Kibana, das, dass, dass die coolen Leute sagen,
das ist Elk, Elastic Search, Logstash, Kibana klingt zu doof, deswegen ist der Elk Stack,
weil besser, Spacewalk, das verwendet noch jemand, der hat mal einen ehemaligen Dokumentator,
der hat immer gesagt, der Spacewalk, der konnte Spacewalk nicht aussprechen, hat immer auf
hessisch gesagt, der Spacewalk, das ist aber schon ewig her, da hatten wir selbst noch
Spacewalk, Spacewalk ist für Redhead so ein Management-Frontend, Web-Frontend, wo du
ein bisschen Redhead-Systeme rudimentär mitmanagen kannst, nicht mal rudimentär, kannst du relativ
viel mitmachen, Spacemark, Forman, Catello, Catello hab ich noch nie gesehen, dass das
jemand einsetzt, Forman ist für Puppet so ein Web-Frontend, ja gut, das klingt doch
eigentlich ganz ok, wir bieten an, steile Lernkurve, ob das jetzt so eine gute, ob das
so toll ist, was man anbietet, ich finde das ist gar nicht schlecht geschrieben, ganz ehrlich,
warum nicht, Musik ist aus, warum ist die Musik aus, oh Support, Ellenville Hair Company,
klingt ja schon wieder absolut Big Brain, oh das ist Mode, Mode Zeug, the Frazier, ey
das wäre glaube ich der optimale Job, mal angenommen man hätte Friseur gelernt und
dann Fachinformatiker, dann wären wir hier richtig gut aufgehoben, Ratbacher, hier wahrscheinlich
eher Ratbacher, das ist, die Experten-Frontend ist das irgendein Personalverschacherungs-Ding
oder, ja das ist irgendein Personalverschacher-Typ, das denn, Sopra, Patenprogramm, ok du hast
permanent einen bei dir, der dir auf den Sack geht, Beratung als Reisen, IGIT, gefahrt,
aber heute ist gar nicht so viel Mist dabei gewesen, war das schon in der Windows 2008,
ernsthaft, im Moment wo war mal, hier, Redhead 6, fuck alter, Redhead 6, ist ja antik, 7 wird
noch Supported, 2008 keine Ahnung ob das noch Supported ist, aber das ist auch schon
ganz schön alt und jünger, ok, man hätte auch neuer schreiben können, was haben die
sonst noch, Apache, Apache Reverse Proxy, JBoss, IES, SVN, ok die sind oldschool unterwegs,
Erfahrung mit der Programmiersprache, SQL, Bash, CMD, IGIT, MySQL, MSSQL, Oracle, ja,
also die bekannte Programmiersprache, MSSQL, MySQL und Oracle, aber SVN ist das beste,
also Reise, Reisegeschichten, das würde ich schon aus dem Grund nicht machen, erfahr,
was unsere Aufgaben, deine Perspektive, Erfahrung im technischen Betrieb von teils hoch verfügbaren
Fachleuten, ja was, sind das jetzt unsere Aufgaben oder meine Perspektiven, also was
soll dieser Satz sagen, dass die Erfahrung haben im technischen Betrieb von, wer hat
das, wer hat das nicht im Administrationsbereich, die meisten Sachen sollen 24 7 verfügbar
sein, die Betonung liegt auf Säulen, du sollst das haben, ok, aber dafür gibt es ja unsere
Erwartung, deine Fähigkeiten, ok, was auch immer, oh, so viel Keck weh, so Leute, wie
gesagt, war heute etwas planloser, spontan stream, eineinhalb Stunden, ich bin einfach
morgen gekommen, es gab ja nichts, ich hatte nichts großartig vor, aber es war trotzdem
schön, dass so viele Leute dabei waren, exzellent, ich denke mal wir sehen uns morgen, Nachmittag
oder so wieder, ich habe nämlich wirklich mal Bock drauf, wieder ein paar Stunden Battlefield
3 zu spielen, vielleicht auch im Stream machen, vielleicht machen wir noch ein bisschen Technik
Kram morgen, müssen wir mal gucken, und ich würde sagen Chat, wir sehen uns, machts gut,
bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.